this is obviously very important this
question grand illan if there were one
character Hodor
that you wish hadn't been killed with
her hey with a big photo well I mean
this to people obviously one is someone
who was a magnificent presence in the
series who happens to be hosting this
panel and also Catelyn Stark big answer
real answer Alfie who died likes people
back to life
yeah pretty much um I would say Karl
Drogo
I like definitely felt over comic and
you oh you have to say that don't say
that okay not you Atlin and um I'm still
hurting about Ned he'll break my heart
takes a while to get over that one I
also have a flame for Barristan Selmy
oh we're not fasting i I just really
loved working with Jack Gleeson so much
that I have to say Joffrey
Wow it's such a good husband haha
re generous man yeah I have no choice I
have to say my baby girl serene at still
hordes big time I think I am still
heartbroken about her door like I still
I honestly just can't quite fit into it
but I you know I just love you what your
guys like whole thing so I think my
answer is is Hodel okay
like so many yeah two answers again
first and foremost become the
illegitimate Aries Robb Stark and the
second answer is if there's one
character that I wish they hadn't killed
it'd be Jon Snow
just to say was having to talk about
every five minutes for a year
whole year was pretty bad that was a
pretty curl me yeah yeah you know I have
to go out in the newspapers if I thought
someone asked me for like 37th time the
our is John snow coming back and I just
lost it I was like new off I don't care
that I'm next day in the paper it said
Christian earn hates hit hard thing like
I didn't say that Isaac yeah you be very
careful Jay yeah some of the dollars I
bring my photo I could even like this
are wolf step use second everything is
the legs actually so you
you